[Music]
what's going on guys
last night was the 2019 Academy Awards
Hollywood's longest and slowest awards
show and that also means it's time for
the grouchy's screen junkies most aced
aliy thrown together video it's almost
midnight right now so let's get this
show on the road shall we let's kick
this sucker off with a biggie it's a
screen junkies tradition the BuzzFeed
memorial gif of the night the nominees
are Spike Lee's confused reaction to
Aquafina Sam Rockwell's confused
reaction to Melissa McCarthy's favorite
cosplay Richard II grant being mega
stoked about Barbra Streisand and the
winner is Chim Chim cheroo
it's keegan-michael Keys MARY POPPINS
entrance sukkot Michael Rooker
Keegan's on your corner now next up the
Christian Bale oh good for you
award where friends say oh good for you
and mean it here are the nominees
Christian Bale applauding his makeup
team Guillermo del Toro presenting
Alfonso Cuaron with Best Director and
the winner Samuel Jackson being so
excited to give Spike Lee an Oscar I
mean the yell the hug Charley what
guys good for you this ain't the Kids
Choice Award nor the Teen Choice Award
it's the mom Choice Award for the most
mama proof moment of the night the
nominees are green book winning multiple
awards Barbra Streisand taking the stage
and the winner Bette Midler singing a
song from Mary Poppins you might not
have given a crap about that but he all
got moms and they all love beaches and
that moment was mom tastic whoo this
award is hot and steamy
it's the they're doing it right award
this goes to the couple who is doing it
right and the winner Bradley Cooper and
Lady gaga the award aside I mean those
two like stuff went down they're doing
it I don't know if they're currently
doing it but they did it and maybe they
even did it again cuz the characters in
the movie did it and in real life they
also did it and that look that they gave
each other when they did the song were
far from the shallows now but guess what
we also did it oh and for those of you
might be confused by doing it I'm
talking about sex laugh it up fuzzball
this is the it could have been you solo
award and the winner Lord and Miller for
taking home the Best Animated Feature
Oscar for spider-man into the spider
verse kind of confirms that if they
included war Han and ham solo in solo a
Star Wars story would have been way
better right and speaking of Spider
versus awesome Easter Egg cutting to
Raimi's Green Goblin during their
acceptance speech well played
oh here comes a goodie it's the it's a
no for me dog award that goes to your
favorite American Idol appearance at the
Oscars the nominees dile Oscar zero one
to vote for Adam Lambert Oscar zero two
for Jennifer Hudson Oscar zero three for
Ryan Seacrest or Oscar zero four for JLo
we'll have the winner right after this
nobody won't this is just a bit it's
time to get those bulls on parade with
thee was that rage against the machines
tom morello award and the winner rage
against the machines tom morello for
making us all ask was that rage against
the machines tom morello oh and by the
way yes yes it was oh it's about to get
trendy cuz it's time for the grouchy
trend of the night here's the nominees
hats rabbit cloaks Pharrell's camo tux
with shorts and the winner ruffles tons
of ruffles on stage on the red carpet
you know I was about to say ruffles you
can't wear just one but that's a slogan
for a different chip so I guess I'll
just go for myself
next up the soap you want a Best
Supporting Actress Award and the winner
is Chris Evans for helping Regina King
up to the stage after she won her Best
Supporting Actress Award where she gave
a great speech and you know what nothing
but respect for King and nothing but
respect for my captain good luck in that
end game it's time for an ad from our
sponsors I mean it's time for the
weirdest commercial of the night award
and the nominees are endless ads for the
show whisky Cavalier Laura Dern walking
by a TV advertising mariette to
advertise the Academy Museum and Ridley
Scott's sci-fi fantasy commercial thing
and the winner
Walmart's bizarre advertising campaign
about people behind the scenes wearing
Walmart clothes I mean what exactly were
they going for hey are you under
appreciated overworked and underpaid you
probably where Walmart you peasant ah
yes you can get into the Vanity Fair
after-party and you can get into Sam's
Club Walmart no time for losers because
this next award is the biggest winners
of the night award and the
winner is royalty Regina King Spike
Lee's omage to Prince Olivia Colman
playing a queen Queen Latifah Queen
opened the show rami malek won as
frontman of Queen Lord and Miller Lady
Gaga you get it last night was a regular
royal flush
I've never played a hand of cards but I
heard that that is a thing milady this
next one is a thankless award
it's the thanks but no thanks award the
award for someone who should have been
thanked but uh just got left off the
list and the winner is the oscar-winning
VFX team behind first man not thanking
Stanley Kubrick because we all know
Stanley Kubrick filmed the fake moon
landing it was shot in a warehouse in
North Hollywood rewatch The Shining all
of the signs are there if we'd been to
the moon then everyone would know that
the earth is flat perhaps you're
wondering why you've been summoned here
it's because it's the mystery of the
night award the winner Spike Lee's big
ol bleep all right I want to thank Tanya
Jackson satchel what a mystery we'll
never know what he was talking about
just kidding
it was Spike Lee and Samuel Jackson of
course they were telling us to shut the
up by the way black clansmen good
movie
this little grouchy is the Highlander
award for the actor who has never aged
and the winner samuel l.jackson this is
Sam Jackson he's 70 this is george RR
martin also 70 he's the same age what
the hell's going on what's his secret I
mean what kind of deal with the devil or
portrait of Dorian Gray does he own did
Marvel permanently D a gym for the movie
Captain Marvel and it just like stuck
good Sam this right here is the grouchy
for best speech a lot of speeches last
night but there is no competition the
winner Olivia Colman no jokes here this
was really great it's just a surprise
winner plenty of emotion off-the-cuff
really appreciative and close I you've
been my idol for so long and this is not
how I wanted it to be and I think you're
amazing you know she was a great
performance and a really good movie I
got to tell you that speech was my
favorite hey everybody it's the wolf
that's uncomfortable award the winner is
this pre-show interview with Jason Momoa
one thing I've got to get out of you I
got to get a hawk a moose
I got to get like one Hawk remove like
come on boy that was uncomfortable that
interview was so awkward
they couldn't even land the handshake
that was uncomfortable and lastly the
one you've all been waiting for
it's the she's finally won award and the
winner is Toni Collette in hereditary
for finally winning Best Actress at the
2019 Fangoria chainsaw Awards presented
simultaneously with the Oscars but just
on Twitter Congrats
Toni you didn't take home any Oscar gold
but now I guess you can cut down a tree
did they give you an actual chainsaw at
me Fangoria I wants to know well that
was the 2019 grouchy's what do you think
what was your favorite award of the
night in the grouchy's or in the actual
Oscar show what did we leave out let us
know in the comment section below
oh he wants to know I want to thank you
for watching screen junkies I want to
thank everybody who edited this help
write this and staying up late to make
this happen thanks again for watching
I'm how rotten it hit me up on Twitter
and Instagram bye bye